Well,
I was very heartened Jordan's by your affirmation of the objectivity of moral
values and duties.
You said there are things that are unquestionably good and unquestionably evil,
but these moral values are not things that are infected,
but they are discovered.
And I couldn't agree more and I would want to push you on this to say that this
very consideration ought to help you to move through naturalism and beyond
naturalism to a transcendent ground for the objectivity of these moral values
and duties because they won't be found in naturalism.
The naturalist is trapped in the lower story.
Uh,
objective.
Moral values and duties are not physical entities described by the laws of
nature.
These are transcendent realities,
either play tonic or else grounded in God.
Um,
and therefore the very affirmation of the objectivity of moral values and
duties.
It was so strong throughout your talk I have,
which I just so appreciate it.
So it's anti relativistic,
it's objective as stick.
I want to,
I want to encourage you to push through that naturalism to finding a
transcendent ground for these in via awesome.
I think that's the most plausible moral theory that will enable us to affirm the
objectivity of these moral values and duties.
Yup.
All right.
I've tried to work out the sorts of ideas that I portrayed in this talk today
within a naturalistic framework as much as possible
because the naturalistic technique is so powerful,
not least for that,
but also because there's glimmerings in the scientific literature of
the sorts of ideas that you portrayed when you mentioned that the evolutionary
biologists are increasingly making the claim that morality is a biological
adaptation and I think you can make a very strong case for that much stronger
case than has actually been made so far.
Um,
I think there is a,
a very sophisticated ethic that has evolved that we recognize as a consequence
of the evolution of our cognitive and emotional structures.
I think that that recognition manifests itself in admiration.
You know,
people are very imitative.
It's one of the things that characterizes us in contradistinction animals who
are not very imitative.
It's probably they're preconditioned for our linguistic capacity.
One of the things that characterize this human existence is the capacity to
spontaneously pick a model for emulation,
right?
And model for admiration.
And that's the manifestation of that moral instinct to say,
well to admire is to want to copy say,
well,
what do you want to copy?
What you want to copy that which is most admirable?
What is most admirable?
Well,
what is most admirable that starts to become a,
that starts to become a transcendent question,
right?
You can imagine that the,
the,
the local examples of what's admirable there,
right in front of you and,
and,
and their concrete and tangible.
But to abstract out from that,
that which is admirable in and of itself is simultaneously to construct
something like the representation of a transcendent good.
And that's to some degree how religious conceptions emerged from their
underlying biological substrate.
Now you might say,
well that's merely reducing the religious conceptualization,
the religious abstraction of what's good to the biological sub strait.
And I think you can read it that way,
but I don't think that that necessarily indicates what it is.
I think that the entire process of evolution is somehow shaping itself around
maybe platonic ideas,
something like that,
some transcendent good and that it's a mistake to assume that just because you
can make an association between the transcendent abstract good and the process
of evolution,
that one is necessarily reduceable to another.
It doesn't,
the way reality works commit
the genetic fallacy to try to say that because one's moral beliefs originated
through such a biological evolutionary process that therefore they are explained
away and have no objective validity that that just,
yeah,
I think partly what happens too is that
at that level of analysis,
you have to start questioning your initial presumptions,
liked the idea that the most true truth is objective because I'm not sure it is.
I don't think we understand what constitutes truth very well and there's the
truth that you act out as well as the truth that tells you what the world is
made of and those aren't necessarily the same thing.
And so things get very murky at that level of obstruction.
But one thing I have learned from attempting to reduce religious preconceptions
to their biological substrate is that there's always something left over that
you haven't explained,
and it's,
it's not something trivial because every time I look into what's leftover,
it turns out to be an ultra bleat deep.
Then I get rid of some more of it and the rest becomes unalterably deep.